so the Babylon 5 the way home trailer
has dropped
welcome to such a kiss Sci-Fi TV and
Movie Channel but anyway this is how
this is going to work
um the trailer hasn't dropped yet in
real time for me right now in this
moment so I'm going to tell you what I'm
looking forward to what I'm hoping for
what I expect and then the trailer is
going to hit at 5 pm here in the UK and
following that I'm then going to tell
you about the trailer and you know react
live to it maybe
so what am I actually expecting I'm
expecting this to feel like Babylon 5
I'm expecting the tone and the style to
be very similar obviously it's written
by the original Creator J Michael
strasinski JMS and um I really expect
this to be done faithfully to the
original series if it isn't and if
they're trying to do something a little
bit different it kind of
loses the point of doing it in the first
place
now a lot of people said they don't like
animation they don't like animated
movies they don't work and they're not
looking forward to this project but I
really am because an animated project is
the only way we can actually get
something that is set in the Babylon 5
era because obviously the actors have
all got much older or actually in a lot
of cases sadly passed away so we cannot
get any more Babylon five the original
Babylon 5.
well now we are going to be hopefully
getting a rebooted version of the series
but for now we've got a chance to
actually get a new original Babylon 5
episode but the only way to do it is
animated so it's got to feel like a
Babylon 5 episode first thing
I expect the story to be linked back to
something that happened in Babylon 5
originally I expect this new story to
add to the law of Babylon 5 to add to
the Canon maybe to explain a few things
I know this um zafras is going to be in
it and we've got the machine maybe it'll
explain a bit more about that enormous
machine that you know could generate and
create temporal Rifts I'd love to know
more about that and I'm really looking
forward to seeing that character again I
expect this to be quite action-packed I
have seen the little clip the JMS dumped
on Twitter yesterday that just basically
gave us a very very teasing brief look
and to be honest I saw the Shadows which
you and I did see some very exciting
look in action but I want action that
again adds to the story not action
fraction's sake and I expect this again
to be grounded in reality obviously this
is an animated cartoon So in theory they
could do anything
and that is cool but I expect it going
back to my first point though to still
feel like Babylon five so I expect that
action to be grounded and to be relevant
to the story and to be honest JMS is a
genius of that sort of thing so I'd be
shocked if it wasn't finally I'm looking
forward to some surprises I'm hoping
that this is going to drop a few little
things to tease us to make us look
forward to this it's going to be
released very very soon so I expect to
be surprised by this I'll come back to
you in a couple of minutes and tell you
exactly though what I think
five minutes later okay so I've seen it
now I have to go on Amazon to get it so
it's going to be available on sort of
DVD Blu-ray 4K all that sort of thing it
looks like it's going to be available
for download as well just like we said
it would be um a couple of months ago so
that's completely what um a guy that I
spoke to said
is how we would get it a couple of
months ago now so no surprise there um I
was surprised I had to go to Amazon to
actually watch the trailer it took me a
minute to to find it which was a little
irritating but we got there in the end
um what do I think of the trailer it's
exactly what I was expecting lots of
action lots of fighting I'm looking one
bit the um spoiler if you've not seen it
but at one bit um there's this
um weapon goes off there's this massive
shock wave and it takes out three or
four Shadow vessels that just looks very
cool there's a massive scene actually
where it looks like Babylon 5 gets blown
up but against an alternate universes it
looks like the time traveling Ultimate
Universe thing is an accident which I
wasn't expecting I was expecting that to
be something to do with zathra but it
actually looks like no it's he's there
at a sort of a resetting facility thing
and he's like suddenly the powers up and
he's like oh oh and what powers this and
it goes it's tachyon this goes oh boy
and then he gets stuck in sliding
through and time and
um alternate universities the one I like
is like I said that the shadow War I
actually lost it
um at one point no one blames you it's
fine he's like what
um so he has to come back to Babylon
five there is a lot of action in this it
looks like it's going to be a
fascinating storyline
um it does this look like it's going to
be an animated Babylon 5 movie and who
can argue with that so guys get over to
Amazon I will 100 not be able to put the
advert here out of the trailer here
because it will almost certainly trigger
um copyright but I will um see if I can
get a link to and I'll put it into the
description so get over to Amazon and
check it out if you're new to the
channel don't forget to like subscribe
do all those bits that you need to do
and hey get into the comments tell me
what you think are you excited about
this will you be buying it I will be and
I'll probably give it away once it comes
out you know as a as a giveaway or
something but we'll see it turns out
good it is I'd say to keep it
um otherwise
um as always guys please stay safe and
I'll catch you next time
foreign